uh
let's talk about some of the questions
yeah we got one here uh what you got
anna any tips on how or when to find a
mentor
any tips on when and how to find a
mentor it's a great question
let me tell you something if you're
looking
your mentor will find you
if you're not looking nobody's going to
look to mentor you
right you know um
you know who benefits the most from
having a mentor
you know we would say the person that
gets the mentor that's right
but emotionally the mentor feels good
man
man people want to help people want to
help you
people like answering why do you think
i'm doing this i think we are we
charging people this no i want to help
people
the mentee benefits because they're
going to learn right they're going to
learn
they're you know like an apprenticeship
internship yeah
but the mentor benefits because they
feel like they're doing something
they're giving back they're utilizing
their
knowledge they're utilizing their
credibility
for the good and the betterment of
someone else and it does feel good like
this feels good
helping people here so go find yourself
a mentor
and ask around the worst thing you can
do is just be a wallflower if you're
looking for a mentor
start asking around especially in the
field that you're looking into
if you don't know what you're going to
do maybe just you know talk to an older
person that's successful
they'll tell you where to go but find
yourself a mentor
here's a couple other questions we'll go
ahead there's another good one here go
ahead ricky yeah okay uh from ricky
aguirre he says ricky aguilar no not our
friend ricky i guess why i honor ricky
shout out ricky why ayata uh ricky says
i saved what i thought was a significant
amount and i lost it all
should i pay down my debt first before i
invest into something again
okay is there a way to find out how much
he had that he lost at all
ricky if you're listening how much did
you lose okay but he said he
we read the question one more time i
saved what i thought was a significant
amount and i lost it all
should i pay down my debts first before
i invest into something again
yes well i don't know what happened with
our friend ricky and ricky
um i feel for you bro i don't know what
happened to
all the money you saved and how you lost
it all something's telling me dogecoin
i'm feeling dogecoin on this or crypto
and like you saved then you just lost it
all i don't know what happened
but um
[Music]
the answer is to pay off your debt so
now he lost it all and he has debt
what happened i'd love to follow up with
ricky maybe we can get ricky on a call
like ricky says his number how do you
lose it
ricky how'd you lose tell you what get
ricky's number ricky let your number
r we're gonna have ricky on the show
next time sure so the next time we were
realizing here is we can go through
these stories pretty fast obviously the
first
15 minutes aren't going to be explaining
who saws is and the
point of the sauce cast we'll have a lot
more time for collins get ricky's number
we'll get him on the phone we're going
to find out
what happened but my quick answer to you
is the best return on your investment
is paying off that debt find out what
the interest rate is on the debt
one time i asked the guy i said how much
debt do you owe two thousand dollars i
said
uh okay what's the interest rate no clue
i said pull out your app on your phone
it was a chase account you had a chase
credit card
he pulled out his phone he pulled out
the chase app
he was paying 24.9 percent i said do you
know how bad that is he goes no i
actually don't i go look
if you're investing you hope to make 10
that's a pretty decent return on your
investment 10 percent so you're
2.5 xing
the wrong way so if you're
if this is a credit card get that find
out what the interest rate is get that
crap
out of your life asap um here's a couple
questions and answers from
people we'll go through this real fast
well maybe we'll try to wrap up in the
next five minutes yeah sounds good let's
do rapid fire q a
this is from people that ask me
questions on my instagram account
sas talks money follow and subscribe on
valuetainment if you're not
so you can be one of the people that
gets your questions answered
here we go this is from john thierfelder
he's a great football player hopefully
he's listening he says what sales
industry would you recommend for a
person beginning
in sales any industry learn
sales they used to say selling is
telling tell them what you need no
selling is asking questions
selling is asking questions another
question was joseph
112 this is how did you learn to sell i
learned to sell
my first job out of college i worked for
clear channel radio and i
sold airtime that's not tangible you
can't sell a product you can't sell it
and it was all needs analysis why are
you looking to advertise what is
what would advertising do for your
business what is there a particular
product or a night that you want to
promote what are you looking to do
how can i help you what are you looking
to do questions questions questions get
to their needs find out what they're
looking for and help them so amazing
book
that you could two amazing books you can
look into is
how to win friends and influence people
if you care about other people and
genuinely ask questions and generally
hear what the answers are
you're gonna go far in life man that
just is what it is and then number two
there's something called qbs
question based selling ques selling
isn't telling
ask questions so for john fearfelder i
think that's how you say your name
i would start somewhere but then here's
not that's where you start should not
bring you where you end up
i started selling air time i think the
most amount you can make i ask people
around find out
what you know what the upside is you can
make 100 grand maybe then i started
getting into financial sales you can
make unlimited potential
so what's the amount of money that you
because whatever you're selling
you know it's just you're selling it
comes down to what you can make
a couple other questions here would you
suggest robin hoods this is from
cmc taiji they said would you suggest
robin hood or acorns to kids to learn to
safe
um acorns is good because it
it basically just rounds up your money
but essentially
and this is something that meet kevin
said it associates spending with
investing and i actually agree with him
that's
those are two different things spending
is not investing but i do respect acorns
but if i had to pick one out of the two
i'd pick robinhood because that's where
you can actually
invest but i think both are great
options um
follow-up question with that this is
from benny j says best broker to set up
a brokerage account thoughts on target
date funds best broker to set up a
brokerage account
uh look i've got a vanguard account
i've got fidelity i've got wealthfront
i've got betterment i've got individual
stocks
the choice is yours that's my point is
like they're all reputable
robinhood weeble betterment wealthfront
fidelity vanguard charles schwab they're
all great find out what works for you
like don't trust anyone that says this
is the best and that's the one it is
how do they know find out what works
best for you interfaces like
fidelity i have it it's the interface
isn't so great
robin had got great interface so find
out works best for your thoughts on
target date funds they're great
my 401k i max out my 401k it's 19 000
a year i get it maybe some of you can't
max out your 401k
you can certainly maybe try to max out a
roth ira that's only six thousand
dollars
but i have my 401k in a target date fund
set for
20 60 or whatever the year is and it
just does it for you look into that if
that you have a 401k
uh here's another question this is from
rad 24
mj or lebron come on bruh mj
mj are you kidding me that's the goat
there's no other discussion
i mean it starts with mj and then it
goes down from there paul would you
agree
absolutely thank you paul thank you for
turning your mic back on
best wealth building strategy i mean you
know where i'm going with this
save that money save that money but
before you can invest like our friend
ricky
i invested i lost all my money no
investing
is not something that you know you're
going to lose all your money
save that money so you have a nice nest
egg an emergency fund a rainy day fund
then you invest do you have a number
you'd recommend to the ten thousand
dollars
ten thousand then invest
gotcha get to 10 g's then invest
something you ever had ten thousand
dollars in a bank account you ever had
ten jobs
once yes at once no not not
a thousand
when it happens dude it's gonna feel
great paul you've ever had 10 gay in
your bank account yes sir my man
paul's my man paul what age were you
when you had 10 grand in your bank
account
don't say 25 no uh god
30 something how did that feel seriously
it felt amazing felt awesome i remember
being having 10 grand in my bank account
first time i was 27 years old dude i
thought i was the king of the world
i actually went i was dating a girl at
the time i remember going i think i
probably a little more than 10 grand
maybe like 13 grand
i remember going to an atm getting the
receipt
and accidentally dropping the receipt
so she can pick it up and be like oh my
boy ballin
it felt awesome go get you 10 grand um
we broke up shortly after yeah if you
enjoyed that short clip from the sawz
cast
click here to watch another click here
to watch the full episode or just stay
broke
[Music]